the spider-man far from home trailer has
just dropped and like the end game and
Captain Marvel trailers that preceded it
there's a lot to unpack throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the trailer
as well as the characters that appear in
it there may be some spoilers here so if
you still want some ambiguity with the
characters then I highly suggest that
you turn off now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to the trailer opens with Peter
Parker finally getting a vacation and
heading to Europe in his room Peter
meets Nick Fury for the first time who
confirms that he knows who he is and
that it's finally nice to meet him he
shoots Ned with a tranquilizer and it's
clear that Vita has been picked for an
assignment and is needed for a mission
we see shots of hydro-man throughout the
trailer and ends with Mysterio teaming
up with spider-man to take down Hydra
man hydro man is the typical low-rent
super criminal and has been a member of
the sinister syndicate and masters of
evil he is able to turn his body into
water and in the comic books blame
spider-man for his abilities this caused
him to often attempt to exact revenge on
the webhead but he never succeeded
basically imagine Sandman but water you
get the idea the fact that they are
battling a giant body of water with very
little to swing on really showcases that
spider-man is out of his element if New
York City was in a real-life location
and then one would think it was
purpose-built for the character however
this is Venice so he is already at a
disadvantage I can't wait to see how
this plays into the narrative throughout
the trailer Peter and his class drop by
the landmarks of Venice and it appears
that there is a romance brewing between
him and Michelle I guess her stalking
plan finally worked out and with Liz now
gone Peter and her seem to be connecting
with one another in the trailer it
appears that Mysterio is working
alongside Nick Fury or perhaps even for
him Mysterio doesn't initially have his
fishbowl helmet but this does get shown
by the trailers close in the comic books
Mysterio is one of spider-man's biggest
villains though he is often used for
comedic effect and his first battle with
spider-man he framed the character and
ran a smear campaign against him he is a
magician with a great grasp of hypnosis
and over the years has done several
things such as fake the death of an
and turn spider-man's allies against him
I can definitely see this being the way
that the movie will go and if he manages
to turn both Fury and Michelle against
Peter then he will have beaten the
character in more ways than one Mysterio
likely knows Peters identity too if he
is working with shield so this makes him
infinitely more dangerous okay so the
trailer is incredibly short but it also
has a fun vibe to it that I think will
work really well with the character
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it and if there's anything that I
missed and make sure you leave it in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and check out my
breakdown of the ending of glass which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best not see you next time take care
peace I think that might be salmon in
the trailer book I think that might be
Mysterio pretending to be Sandman just
leave in the comments below what you
think yeah
[Music]